good morning y'all we will
try to start in a couple minutes
assuming
the servers work at 8 am
um but this is eric that's who you're
hearing
uh let's see
ah
okay
we also got a bunch of
um videos and
different things going up at 8 am um
regardless of if we can't play
um
i have a cinematics comparison just the
old versus the new
we also have some gameplay going up of i
believe act five
since that hasn't been seen like outside
of a trailer
um there's also going to be
some cow level uh which is great i'm
gonna confirm something today
to see if killing the cow king will
actually like
cause you to like lose um
you know your cow level or if it's if
you could just keep going i think what i
saw from a community post was that you
could
just keep going
which is great of course didn't have
that before
we're t minus three minutes roughly
we'll see if we can get in
the other thing i can try to do
potentially
is
we do have
like our early review code and i don't
know if that's different than
like when it's live but we could also
try that at 8 am if it doesn't work
i was told i think that my um
online characters would port over but
the um
offline characters wouldn't
for fun i did try like loading in some
offline saves and that did work
that's something we could try as well
if we want to do that later um some of
the ones that i grabbed from just like
the internet aren't
anything like
well i should say that they're
definitely like hacked up the wazoo
where they have
um
you know either
uh like plus skilled charms that have
like seven plus skills on the thing
audio is way low can i turn on my mic
yeah i can do that sorry i'm like waking
up
turn it up in
um obs and then also try to turn it up
on my actual mic and i'll speak louder
um
feels like a new year i
i hope so
was there always assassins chris there
was assassins with lord of destruction
not in the base diablo 2 game though
yeah i i definitely have a trap assassin
that was what i made only because
i personally would actually if like
all things considered i'd probably go
sorceress first
um
but
just because i think you you read mf
better
than any other class and you know
teleport obviously
but
i wanted to see like another class that
wasn't in the alpha and the beta
um
black lax ca says home is on switch i
don't know what that means
i'm checking chat as much as i can
i'm going to be playing on pc
we'll see if this triggers at at um
8 am or not the mike's 100 better thanks
wingzero uh and also
then quantum and also frank for speaking
up there apologies on that i just
literally took two sips of my coffee and
tried to fire up the stream so we'll see
um t minus a minute
and we will see
if it works right away
uh last time for alpha beta for me i
think it took like
oh boy it took like
i don't know 10 minutes maybe 10-15
minutes before
um
it actually like okay it's 8 am right
now
and i don't here i can show you my
launcher
oh no that's me surprise did it again
there you go
um sorry too many scenes
can't wait to play my amazon yeah
amazon's a good one too i really like
amazon amazon you can get pretty far
without really needing anything right
you just kind of want to have make sure
like so i have this d2 early review
version i could try that
um and it'll probably work
uh
you can check for updates now we're up
to date
uh
i'm about to i'm literally about to play
this one just because i i bet you it
works um this was our early review code
uh i only got through normal on the
assassin because we kind of got it a
little late and then of course trying to
juggle that and make content is kind of
hard but
we can at least see all through normal
and start someone nightmare i think i
need to level a little bit i'm just
going to launch um
this earlier view just to see if it
works
still
in theory it should and in theory my
embargo is 8 am
so oh hopefully this audio is not held
allowed for you guys oh jk
my early access one doesn't work anymore
i don't think
oh no it does okay
um one sec let me
switch to this except now this thing is
like the resolution got bored
so this is um
that's our all the offline ones huh
oh
my online characters don't work but
we could play offline oh nope
[Music]
i need to go back to the launcher
it's trying to do the online but then
it's not
so the only reason why i can even dude
this is probably like super loud it's
super loud for me i'm going to turn this
down a little bit or try to hopefully
the audi the game audio is not super
loud um
oh
yeah okay uh that's currently not
working so
one sec
let me go back to that really quick um
all right i'm gonna exit out sorry
sorry to get everyone's hopes up there i
thought it was gonna oh wait uh d2
normal works now so
let's go back to that
here we go let's try that
now i don't need to close it we got it
game audio done yeah i got to do it in
the game um arya i'm really sorry
oh game is loud i know i know let me let
me try
[Music]
all right so this is proper retail all
right here's my characters all right we
are good to go let's do it huh um jeez
please diablo calm down i know it's
we're i know you resurrected from the
dead but
oh hello okay
uh so there's i only made two online
characters they did get ported over i'm
gonna play the trap assassin i probably
need to play
through
um
i probably gotta get to like level 40 or
45 before going to a
nightmare to be fully candid i think at
some point i probably even need to
change it into like um
uh
geez i can't speak um it's a lightning
trap because right now i'm all i'm very
pretty much like full wake of fire
um
which is fine in normal but it's
probably not gonna work so great in
nightmare uh we could even do cow level
right now if you guys want to see cow
level or we can save that for later
um
also i don't have anything amazing any
any of the stuff i got was oh also this
was a fun one
i got this two-socket breastplate and
it's totally my fault but i think this
is like an old bug too where like it had
a magical like
um like prefect suffix on it but it had
nothing on it
and so i just like in my mind i just
kind of like jammed it for stealth and
yeah anyways
uh
all right let's see let's see nothing on
switch yet the uk just opened sick sick
sick everyone getting in awesome uh
let's go take a look here look we
haven't y'all haven't really well
outside of like
um
uh outside of trailers you nobody's
really seen the three acts right i mean
not three actually um
act three looks really good
our buddy ormis
um
switches up some people say nice there's
ashara
so you know act 3 is looking good uh you
know
cross docks here
we can go we can go i i was never a fan
of act three to be honest because of how
much running you have to do i don't know
if it like what's everyone's favorite
act and which one is uh everyone's least
favorite act
i think act three is mine um
i liken it to like
act two of um
d3
i'm all over the place yeah i know just
excitement
we'll do some activity although this is
not the best you know what we should do
um hold on
if we're gonna farm we should probably
farm xp at a level we should probably go
to um
traffic we can even kill we can't even
go kill me so
um
let's go to travicle how many people did
traffic runs back in the day
the hydra is looking good even though
they're not mine mike
merc died already that's great
uh tell me if the mic is still okay or
not
elrone out of it
dark magic here is dispelled
so if you guys have a question if you
all have questions or anything you want
to see just hit me up we'll try to we'll
try to do as much as we can
yeah the spells look really good um
review when um the reviewer should
hopefully be done in the next couple
days i would imagine maybe sooner it's
hard to say um we kind of got code a
little late
to be honest um
so
[Music]
it's always left right
watch i say that and i'm wrong oh no no
i was taking those upstairs
windows switch version release somebody
said it it's out already but i i can't
confirm i'm playing on pc right now so
i just know it's working because
we're playing right now um and it's not
the review code anymore it's just
straight up the uh
launch
launch version
mine says i can't play the game yet
oh it was so close uh tp for safety
pc is not live yet i don't know i i got
it up and running on retail um
i back out to show you but i didn't do
anything special i promise you that i
did all i did was preload last night
uh so here's math
that looks pretty good
remember when you would like off screen
them with a like a blizz sword right
there you just like do it over the boat
he drops
pretty much bad
stuff
how good does it look on switch i
haven't seen it on switch yet renard
i would imagine fine though given given
diablo 3 with mine on
uh given diablo 3 was fine on
thingy
on switch
although i guess this may be more
intensive than d3 in a way
did they nerf assassin not that i know
but again we're only playing on normal
right now so trying to level up a bit
while showing some new stuff and then
we'll make our way to nightmare but i
probably like i mentioned earlier i
probably have to respect the lightning
trap
and also
i don't have any claws right now that
give plus two traps which would kind of
be bad i'm using a leaf ruin
um
for the plus three to fire
okay live now restart y'all okay cool
that's what uh to win is saying that
it's a good to go
try restarting if uh it wasn't working
for you you could try as somebody
mentioned earlier to like um
like restart your your client your
battle net client i know that sometimes
they do it in waves so like it might be
working for some people and then not for
others but eventually like over like you
know five to ten minutes
better is this better than d3 personally
on a personal level i think it is but
that's only because i
you know despite playing i mean um not
despite but i played a lot of d3 but i
played
more d2 um back in my time
so i have a nostalgia affinity
and just
i don't know i think i think that
there's
a little bit more wiggle in terms of
like what you can do with your character
ruin words are like amazing
um and then you have mercenaries
technically in this version you have
like a a proper like better pvp
depending on how you look at it
i never got into pvp maybe because i'm
just not good at it but
um that was a thing that you know
diablo 3 didn't really have i think
there's also more room for
experimentation and like like skills
that you can go down because the skill
trees are like
i don't know there's more to them
than d3
personal take though
so this is um
chaos actually these mages look like
amazing
i can try to zoom in i can't really see
him though
oh the other fun thing that i i did
mention that like there's cow level like
um they're all like beefed up here's
what it looks like in the past
i mean i guess they don't look that bad
i tricked you all we're actually playing
classic
is llama playing probably i would have
to imagine so
um if you don't know mr lama sc he's a
pretty good resource for uh diablo ii
um i think he used to speedrun it he
also has a bunch of guides so like
if you're
wondering like oh should i
um
like what should i dang it
what should i go like what build etc
um
he could possibly he has a bunch out
there
um and then like the best way to like
you know start off
oh he's immune to fire sick
he's like why is he not taking damage
there's always like one immune to fire
[Music]
and i need my mercenary to kind of deal
with that i don't have them right now
i guess i probably should have leveled
the sword just to see all the different
magic because like i bet like
you know blizzard well i've seen i've
seen all some of the skills already
because of the trailers but
that's got to be some of the cooler
effects i would imagine
yeah it does support controllers it's
actually not bad um from what i
[Music]
from what i've
played
uh of it
the only thing with controller that i'll
say is not a great experience but it's
kind of the same in d3
is um
inventory management stuff because
it's really a struggle i feel like
it's
you don't think that it's playable on
controller i don't know i thought it was
it was fine it's not great if you're
like used to pc though
uh
let's go see mr diablo
thing
oh maybe not you know why i gotta go
kill that one guy that i couldn't kill
earlier
sell really quick
what do you need
probably doesn't need to be said but i'm
gonna quickly
deposit gold
uh you can use old save files from
original d2 yeah offline you can
you can do that offline i did mess with
that and i did download some old saves
and it didn't work
you can do it
[Music]
oh he killed my merc in one lightning
breath feels good
i should probably not be this close to
be honest
um
oh did we get saigons oh but oh we got a
legendary
let's go see
hello
retails
nope that's not saigon's derp um
we're just getting low-level stuff uh
because
i did get saigon's rap two-piece would
be pretty nice
uh there's also a shared stash if y'all
didn't
know about that
oh can you just auto sort this for me
i made a mess
i probably shouldn't even be keeping
half the stuff i have in here
was in draw
if we made a boaz on
let's put that in there for now
probably just ship that to get that out
of there
okay
act five we go i guess
why can't i launch on pc try reloading
your uh launcher your client see if that
works
um
i think most people did like the other
thing like i mentioned earlier is maybe
um they're just like letting people in
waves in which case like
maybe that's part of it
like the struggles
is that tape playing it is hello
[Music]
chris l how are you doing
brandon is very excited for this
it's
pretty
awesome pure nostalgia for me and it
looks good
so and i'm waiting to
play i i have a couple friends that are
going to come back and play
i don't know i'm just looking forward to
it
i probably have to like uh possibly even
um help them
because
i'm probably ahead at this point
uh so
in your save files or
diablo assuming you have like the d2s
file or uh i might be butchering the
the the file type but like
you can go into like i think it's like c
users
documents
or no see users and then save games and
then find diablo 2
and then there you should be able to um
move your save files over and then they
should just show up in your offline
characters
if that's the route that you want to go
um and i did try it yesterday and it did
work so
hey you remember
like highland runs
here you know what we should just put
points in the lightning trap just so
that we can see it right
go
f4
all right let's check out lightning
traps
i won't do nearly as much damage
[Music]
oh yeah it is not
yeah it's not gonna do enough damage
right now
we can switch to it though um eventually
probably need lightning sentries and uh
corporate explode one two death entries
yeah you just got to find the right
boulder asap but it 100 works
i mean i can even show it later if we
want i just don't want to run the risk
of like logging off and then like you
know
like getting booted somehow and then not
being on and then everyone's like why
aren't you playing and i'll be like i
went to go test the offline thing and
yeah anyways
i was late to diablo starting with three
that's fine i think i think that if you
enjoyed three there's two is definitely
different um in the standpoint of like i
would say it's a it's definitely harder
um
well that's relative to like i guess
greater rip stuff but like i think in
general it's just a
i don't know
it's the better diablo in my book that's
all i gotta say
and i and i played a lot of three so
you know
hello
i even want that
um if there's anything
people want um
to speak specifically tell me um
otherwise we're kind of just oh you
wanna go see pindle
y'all remember pindle
uh how many people in chat had a pendle
bot
it's okay if you had one i'll say that i
had one
[Music]
i mean he's probably not as good in uh
normal but he was he was definitely
really good in uh
hell difficulty
i really need to clear this inventory
there's some stuff in here that probably
could go
so what's that end game in d2 like uh
the end game is like you farm the same
either bosses or places
over and over basically to get loot
and then you're just trying to get like
uh
better ruins and hope to make the like
god tier ruin words like enigma and like
infinity and
it's all loot in the end right how buggy
is it uh so far so good i think like
maybe some of the like stuff that gets
weird sometimes is like
sometimes you're like
you're like stuck and you're like oh how
did i get hit by that
but like that's the kind of comment i
feel like i would say nothing like
nothing truly catastrophic has happened
to me in the last
day and a half or so playing
i haven't had any crashes
i don't know it's been pretty
[Music]
good so far i'm sure there's people that
are like
already 99 i think everyone just wants
ladder right which is like the one
kind of sad note is like i would have
loved to start that started this um
season with
or yeah season with ladder
oh wow just
just finding the throne of destruction
like it's no problem
here's a succubuy
we'll try to get um
oh these guys wrecked though i gotta be
careful
you know the zoop didn't like isn't as
good as i
thought it would be
take that
did they always use their feet to kick
you
like look at this minotaur oh god
i can't do that view for too long it's
kind of like
how does diablo fight look last hack oh
it looks good um we can queue it up
again uh
be chaotic
i can go back and just reopen a game if
we want to go check it out
it's kind of why i'm just pacing through
some of the the stuff that hasn't been
shown as much in like the trailers that
are like classic so like
you know
the old throne of destruction i'm sure
many people have done multiple runs and
like
um
you know what i do need to do though
i think kalenzo is
fire immune uh what's up
auntie shinsu how are you doing
afternoon
oops
oh that's bad
good afternoon oh the other one thing
that would have been really cool to have
that's not
there
um is
cross play
cross progressions in there
um
but you know there's probably a couple
people and actually i should say a
couple there's probably a lot of people
that are going to be playing diablo for
the first time um and on console which
is or sorry diablo 2 for the first time
and it'll probably be on console and you
know that's that's great too
um
because actually
yeah from what i promote or call on
using a controller on pc it's pretty
good
it's definitely not like um
d3 where it's
fully like designed for console though
if that makes sense like i feel like
the game so i got a head start yeah so
we had early review code so my save my
normal character save um
is just a head so i can show you all
like the axe and show
some of the stuff that we're doing
do you still think we'll get d4
ah
i don't know like i always viewed d2
resurrected as if they ever came out
with it which obviously they did
um
i always viewed it as this could be the
stop gap to buy them time
now granted not everyone's gonna play
d2 remastered and might be waiting for
d4
i'm not worried yet i think
we'll see what happens in 2022
like if it starts to go to 2023 then
maybe that's kind of tough to this
but
you know i'll probably be playing
this assuming you know they're they're
continuing to update and
do the ladder
you know
i mean i would love um d4 too though but
what's up erican
when does it launch it's technically out
if you if you had bought it and
preloaded i believe
these these one these dinosaur looking
guys were always a problem
it's lister the tormentor right
i should stop trying to admire them and
kill them because they're going to kill
me
i kind of wish they gave like um
like the the main uh enemy type in at
least here world gen the same treatment
they gave the cow king because like cow
king you can actually tell like he's the
king now because he has like a crown
and like he has like like these kind of
like shoulder
pad type thing too
oh i'm so weak
yeah lister the tormentor
okay trying to fire blast him is not a
great idea
hello
uh yeah i mean they don't sadly hassun
there's no roll ability in this one um
someone did mention that on our team
who plays um
uh
d3 and was like i really wish they'd add
that in
bail you looking good
so here's bale
as you saw with killing blisters
oh i tried to heal my
uh brother's driving
build are you using i am using a fire
assassin build right now for normal
um and then i'll probably transition to
lightning trap
and destin
yes entry
and he dead
anyone pc playing it online right now i
don't know i could try to check
be free spirits oh i can't game do not
drop anything good
i am overburdened
he did not drop anything good
i guess we pick it up for the monies
do y'all want to see cow level or do you
want to save it for later or we can just
do it and then do it and go back again
um
35
i think i need good
can you show off the druid also uh i can
try showing off some other characters
yeah
um
the only reason why i haven't
shown the druid is because um
because he was in the uh out the beta
beta he's in the second one
always look for uh those
class items because they sell for a lot
of money if you're worried about dying
and dropping a gold i would put it down
deposit
just like the bank real life
wait what level you say i'm 35 but it's
because i had we had it early um and i
didn't really
go go go all right yes cow all right
dude they are like
basically roided out cows
uh for science and for chat
uh i was saying earlier but like
apparently
you can kill the cow king and there's
like no consequence like you could just
keep cow leveling so we can also test
that theory now just like to 100 confirm
it so here we go
here i'm gonna show you uh
this is a old cow level right
and then look at look at these these
absolute
beefcakes
look they all went to the gym
they all went to the gym
[Music]
so someone asked like what do you do at
the end game you could also do this if
you wanted to do just count level on
like the hardest difficulty
that would be a thing too
[Music]
i'll try to find you the uh cow king
so that you can see the difference too
because he is definitely
there he is so
um he definitely has
enhancements
he would look this way you're killing my
dude
you see
he's got a helmet and a thing and then
if we go old school you all you could do
is like look at his name apart anyways
we're gonna kill him
oh
and then see if uh if i can make another
game
here in a second after we clear it out
if um we get
another if we can do another cow level
or not
but for now we farm on
burn some cows
is jude the class most people want to
see
if we if we do end up playing like
another one
yes there are cows
this is the secret cow level um
all you need is a rodrick's cube
word's leg
um a tomato portal and you can you can
make it
oh i need some
metapods
finally a rare amulet that could be an
upgrade
that's the other thing about like the
rares in this game like some of them can
be like just like so good compared to
some of the stuff that you get in d3 i
guess like you would actually
in some cases rare rare over just a
legendary whereas like
in d3 i felt like all you're doing is
farming for legendaries
the amazon has black hair on the switch
really
i i have not played the switch version i
was really debating personally if i was
going to drop
like 80 i think to buy it on both
pc and switch
but i decided against my better judgment
i just won pc
um
but
i was tempted because i don't know d3
was pretty good on
on switch but again like i think that d3
was definitely something they probably
had in mind at some point ago console
whereas um
you know probably with with d2
they never really truly truly truly
engaged that right like
i don't know
bovine more like swolvin that's correct
husson they are swole
do a lot of people play diablo uh i
think so i don't know about like if
people like kept playing diablo 3 but i
think it was like
pretty
oh wow 30 mf on a magic okay
see that
see this is the weird stuff that you i
would get excited about because like
dude 30 mf while we're leveling hell
yeah oh and then look at this okay
uh rare rare amulet
just like come on man
i probably don't i'll give that to
someone else some of these charms could
be pretty good for uh
i need that amulet ever yeah maybe for
wait what level is this thing
18
it could be a starter
it could be a starter type amulet all
right let's go test the theory
let's go find out if um we can just make
another
i think this is online if i do this
so here is
oh jeez
it does a good job of telling you what
everything is yeah there is no ladder
right now so this is all the folks
out in the world playing so far or at
least in this probably lobby um
i can go make a
cow run one
actually they probably won't even space
it right you just do cow run one
uh
normal
30 mf is a lot on an amulet um
for anyone that has played sorry so like
if i lost my [ __ ] about 30 mf that that
is a lot on one not one piece especially
when
you're um
[Music]
you know starting off and you don't have
any items oh this is not a good sign
though
did we make a mistake so are people
crashing heaps as chat would say i think
i'm about to crash here
[Music]
uh
so it sounds like you can make your own
lobby
but then like
but then maybe trying to make
one in the general lobby might not be
working
okay thank you kick me out exit the
lobby we just want to play
we just want to play you know day one
hey i'm happy to be online and i was
playing the game now i guess i should
have never left my my room but i mean
you kind of have to do that in diablo
yes
in in yes i would love 200
you know when you when you're first
starting off or a rat what but like if
you think about it
um
we just got what uh
sixty
percent of the way to two hundred sixty
to seventy percent of the way did vnet
just crashed someone said uh it's
possible
we had a good uh 40 minutes of playing
everyone
this is better than uh what was it error
33 though on diablo 3 launch day you all
remember that
um where you just couldn't get in
yeah i'm still playing normal right now
so like to get 30 on one piece i'm i'm
very happy uh what's up keller burger
how you doing how's everyone doing this
morning i hope they're having a great
thursday charms give you plenty of mmf
yeah if you can get if you can find
those charms again
just started only level 36 if we were if
we were playing through like um
ladder you know if you saw 30 mf and you
have a sword like oh man you are you are
happy mf is a magic find j them so the
more magified percentage you have the
higher the higher you have rather it
just helps you find
uh like you know more rare or higher
rare rarity items so
especially when you're you're starting
off like i mean this game is basically
predicated on getting more like loot
right so
all right we got back in
i think
okay mine's crap uh just keep trying i
think the servers are probably just
getting hammered is my guess um
we gotta go to tristram
i need potions and we'll be fine
will we be fine
i don't know i have some re juice
[Applause]
um we're also trying to get a tips video
out um at some point today
you know that's being cut by um
a good pal of mine in the uk adam mason
you might not see him too much on video
at gamespot but he has been on video a
couple times
um he actually helps for anyone that
watches the channel and
watches firearms expert reacts
that is adam and dave and chris morris
in the uk working on that
uh so we'll see if how far he gets and i
told him i could help him finish if
we
uh if he needs it
because it is kind of hard when you uh
have you done any bail runs yet no so i
just tried to go into the lobby just now
like a proper like online lobby and i
couldn't even make a game there
so i'm probably not gonna mess around
too much with that today
uh unless it starts to show stability
later but we're just gonna go back and
do another cow run
probably since we're in this game we're
probably just going to go ahead and do
some more
like other runs uh we can do travancol
again we can do
uh
you know i think i showed all the major
bosses at three to five but we could
also go kill them again if we wanted to
um
a lot of stuff we could do i gotta go
buy some mana pods
i think we oh well here here's the test
nope
so if you kill cow king you can't do cow
again i need to go tell my co-worker
that
oh which kind of sucks
maybe it was a mistake
uh let me just that's unfortunate we
can't kill any more cows than normal but
that's okay
oh wait it does work
it's just super delayed what is that
all right everyone i guess the servers
are just lagging um
yeah they said cal king wouldn't lock
portal that's why i was i was confused
the noob but it it looks like it works
um i finished normal already so
it was just delayed i guess the servers
are just having problems right now oh
whoops i need to go buy pots
so it works for all those that are
curious i did kill cal king the last
last run we were in so
uh afternoon i'm happy to yeah i saw
that report by a community manager too
so that's why i found it weird that um
it wasn't
uh working there but it it's good it's
just latency or
back and server stuff
i should i gotta get used to control
clicking that stuff into the uh
inventory stash all right let's go kill
some more cows
maybe they'll give us another good hot
item like uh like that 30 mf
i have an eagle ring too which i got
lucky to drop but it was a
sadly a poor naval ring it only has 18
nmf i believe
and correct me if i'm wrong i think
angle goes
right or is it 25
it's either 25 or 30. i know that
okay
oh thanks
all right we keep getting the low i've
i don't know this for fact y'all and
maybe it's because i have like uh how
much map do i have this oh it doesn't
actually stay here huh
let me see i have 25
30
uh that's 55 63 73
i shouldn't even be wearing this ring
because it doesn't actually help me uh
so i have like 70 mmf
oh no
the latency is real
only but parts of the game work and
other parts don't
okay we can't id our stuff in our
inventory but we can play the game so i
guess i should complain
uh online is free stone of the jordan i
wish um online is free but
somebody on switch would have to confirm
or deny for me if you have to have
nintendo online to play online because i
remember that was a thing um for diablo
in terms of if you wanted to play online
right
[Music]
which then therefore would be you know
an additional whatever like nine dollars
a month
um
depending on uh
if you already had it or not i guess
does this work yet
do what
no okay
[Music]
the game is out uh launched launch
launch time was 8 a.m
oh that's the other fun thing about this
is like when you when when you all play
multiplayer i don't know if any of you
guys
everyone actually
got a chance to play
the multiplayer offline but you better
get used to picking up stuff fast
because uh
people people be real fast when they
loop
and if you uh want the loot you're gonna
have to be holding alt a lot
and also uh shout outs to pickett for
anyone that knows what that is
yes you have to have uh nintendo online
to play online for switch gotcha thank
you uh
mr wolf nld
[Music]
i can't complain i'm getting a lot of
jewelry and charms right now
that's funny though
[Music]
trying to get to like 40 to go nightmare
but
happy to just show like the acts and
stuff like that that haven't been shown
um
i could try playing necro but like
honestly necro is my like least favorite
class even though he is definitely
viable um
if you have the right gear and the right
spec i just i've
never personally had
that much fun
playing necro we need some new boots we
need a new helm
we need so much
oh let's go 15 mf
we're going we're going full mf here the
cows are given the mf
[Music]
cows are dropping jewelry that is for
sure
um
keep that for a class i can actually use
it
uh look at all these like
stuff that i'm just never
that's that's pretty nice though like
when we make when i make my pally i will
definitely be using that
so yeah i've gotten a lot of the like
low-level
kind of
set items
[Music]
same issue here paladin logged off for
breakdown issues and it deleted your
character it'll probably show back up
given the like how long it took for the
cow level to actually like populate like
it's probably just a server side thing
and it'll be fine
eventually
like i couldn't id stuff just now right
but i could still kill stuff so
i think it'll be
okay
um if there's requests i'll try to
[Music]
try to see if i can build some of those
i always
i feel like they up dropped me or maybe
my mf is really actually influencing
things but like i don't remember getting
this much stuff
when i played
i swear like d2 was so stingy
that's the other thing i would say if
you want to try to learn is like learn
the sounds of the drops so that like you
don't kill something off screen and then
not pick it up
so like jewelry charms ambulance or
sorry jewelry and charms have a very
distinct sound
i don't know that's something you'll
learn all the
[Music]
play d2 resurrected i think that's
totally fine
okay here's here's a weird opinion i
think because i think most people don't
actually like it but i think that most
people actually haven't played it either
i actually like diablo immortals
um and i think context for that though
is that i am now
a father
and
it's kind of harder to play play
something like you know sit down and
play a pc game for like hours like i
used to
and so like
i don't know i enjoyed the mobile
experience that is diablo and you
probably say like well why don't you
just play d3 on twitch or something well
you know obviously my phone's easier to
bring with me but
ah come on give me plus two to traps
so that's another thing we're looking
for is a circlip that has like those two
to traverse that would be
very good i think the other thing we
could do is um
we could do the we can make the helm
that gives plus one to skills i think
it's like it's called board i think it's
word soul and i actually have horse
so we could do that too as like the poor
man's way but you know the easier way
would be to find
dude your game audio is loud yeah i know
um
uh let's try that
it didn't seem to bother anyone earlier
but uh
is the game crack no it's just
um you gotta buy it and i would imagine
it might be hard because i think you
have to always be online
oh no our barbarian friend kicked the
bucket
are there other places that i didn't go
to that are pretty iconic that weren't
in the beta
what do you mean launch today i played
this like was it 20 years ago
i don't even know if we keep this maybe
i think we keep it i think well it's so
stupid like it's not even ladder but
like
um i would definitely put that on a
pally i guess you know depending on uh
what else he has
so i remastered all the cinemax every
master too if you haven't if you want to
see the big difference you can check
that out on gamespot.com right now on
youtube we have the uh we have
the um
cinematics compared to the old one we'll
go to river here you know what we can do
some river flame if you want to see that
the smith doesn't look all too
impressive to be honest uh or not
uh who's the guy with the mallet in um
might be all the way back though
oh i gotta pick that up right
do i was about level five into the
leading character oh that's not so good
um
is that on pc or console
yeah all i can really say is just hope
that um
it's just a server side thing and
that it will probably
at some point show back up uh but that
is rather frustrating if you're trying
to play that character
and i would be really mad if like you
shared staffed shared stash to something
and then you lost it
that would be really annoying
that's actually horrifying
uh
it's like the old days where you would
go make a room and you try to permit so
that you could uh you know
mule your items over and then like if
something happened you're like oh okay
just lost
i don't know like two sages worth or
whatever
um
no
we had a monster trying to i don't see
one though
i wonder i don't know i don't see how
they would do it but i wonder if they're
gonna bring back diablo clone somehow
that would be sick
i've only ever seen diablo clone once uh
and if you don't know what diablo clone
is that's like um what the what the
blizzard did at the time to try to
combat all the sage hacking so they made
it like a mini game where
um if people sold sojs or stone of
jordans that like it would eventually
make a like diablo cone spawn in a game
and it was like random i think uh one
time me and my friend were just muelling
and like you know moving items over and
then i was like oh my god
i think diablo clone just spawned in our
game because it gives you a prompt
um so there's there's hebesto
um so anyways only got him once and then
we had to figure out who got the like a
nihilist charm
or uh i think that's what it was called
denialist chart which was like really
good it was like a small charm that gave
me plus one to skills
um
but
those were fun times
[Music]
what's the difference hold on i gotta
check that message in a second i'd
rather have more
menopause at this point um
sorry part of the chat's cut off sorry
what's the difference between the game
modes like classic
uh visual difference
like we could play like this if you
wanted to see it like okay
example right look at hadrial
this is hadrial
20 years ago
right
he looks all right
and then this is hadrial
20 years later uh he he
he he went he got some cosmetic surgery
you know
uh yeah i'm using firewave assassin
right now i'm just curious
or sorry wake of fire
so max with wake of fire
um and then i have fire blast which i
haven't been using which i probably
should be using
um
because it's it's perfectly good and
fine for normal it might not be so good
for nightmare probably want to switch to
lightning traps at that point
but i also think i'm supposed to like
try to um
check natalia more often i think that's
her name natalia
to try to get plus two
to uh
that's my fire blast damage not very
good um
to try to get claws that give plus two
to traps
so
i don't know if that's at like level 40
though someone in chat might be more
knowledgeable than i am i didn't i
played like a trap sit like
maybe like once or twice in my lifetime
playing
um
d2
i was mainly a paladin and sorceress and
amazon those are my three my main three
uh
classes that i played back in the day
even though i never got an enigma
i was living that poverty life
and then i guess i never hacked back
then either so
can't wait to play this after on my ps5
after i eat says cooper nice nice please
enjoy
happy uh d2r launch day to you
feel like
it's been a long time coming in a sense
like where
you know all i wanted was this game uh
more so than d3 to be honest um at least
with d3 started to get an old
um and they uh made a great vicarious
visions
made a great one
sorcerer yeah you go uh if you play
sorceress blizzard's probably one of the
strongest abilities
and then as um conrad mentioned you just
swap over to frozen worm and you're
probably good to go
you can like the thing about um
the beauty about the sorceress and the
amazon is they can actually off-screen a
bunch of stuff
so like i i had a multi-shot
amazon and i would literally just stand
here and shift attack with multi shot
and it would probably clear
all that stuff here in the corner
see him being fired
oh no
i thought it was uh i thought it was a
legendary
unique whatever
cares about the name i was like please i
want another nagel
it's okay it feels good to loot again
but again it's kind of in vain right now
because it's not ladder so it's a little
bit less meaningful but hey we gotta
start somewhere right
i am looking forward to ladder
um it's gonna be a fun time i think
i did not i don't think i said i hope i
never i didn't say that it's superior
path of x i think path of xl did a bunch
of great things um
you could argue that path of exile was
more diablo 2 than d3 and i don't think
that's a bold statement or claim at all
i'm actually interested okay so i played
a bunch of poe like earlier and i
haven't really kept up even though i
know that game has been supported
tremendously by um grinding gear games
ggg
and they have a very solid player base
and i really do like what they do with
like the ladders and
i
don't play poe as much anymore but i i
do watch the you know the races
um i think it's really cool to to have
those kind of like the hardcore self
it's called like hardcore self find i
think um i'm probably missing a letter
that acronym but
um you know you're racing against other
players to get to 99. and then also
um
you are
you you can't trade right so it makes
that's only one of the leagues they do
multiple leagues
but i think what they did with that and
that concept is really smart and then
they started to really incentivize you
know more so the streamers than anything
else but play maybe players too maybe
just non-shooters like kind of like
partnering with sponsors and
and kind of getting those fun
like hey kill this new boss first on
this specific league and you can win a
laptop right
um which just adds to the race oh no my
poor mercenary
so this is diablo right and this is old
diablo i would say
he looks
a lot better
than his uh
old self
i can't carry anything oh my god we
can't carry anything
oh you can't launch the game i'm sorry
chris stay awhile
um
i just i feel like
i feel like it's every day one lunch
right it's kind of it kind of gets kind
of bad um unfortunately
whoa that's a lot oh wow plus three to
frozen orb
uh i guess we keep that
ah darn only 16 mf but it's got 10 ias
too
if i'm not mistaken i believe uh attack
speed actually influences like traps but
i think for now because we're not
struggling we'll just save that
can't log back into the character
because servers are dead just keep
trying if you have the patience for it
because
um
it it it you will eventually work like i
couldn't boot a game just now and then
eventually it
did its thing so
and i would say if you're in a game
right now like just best practice is
probably don't leave it um if you can
the lightning breath looks more
dangerous than the old version uh maybe
it was also probably just me being bad
and being close to um
diablo
hammered in orbs for the win yeah
hammerden is just really strong
just because um
i think most of his damage can't be a
mute
so like
pretty much always doing like true
damage in a way
and i i didn't mention earlier i tried
to maybe do the offline save stuff but
given all the server issues and that
we're streaming i probably won't take
that risk
for obvious reasons
leave it so i can join i
i'm sorry i will leave it in like
another
maybe hour hour and a half though and
then and then you can join i guess
sorry
never learn from diablo launch i i mean
in general i don't think they learn it's
not that they don't learn from launches
i think and this is just my my theory
and you know
it can be corrected if wrong
it doesn't happen with just like diablo
right like i think
they have a certain expectation
server-wise
in terms of like
capacity
and they don't do anything to ramp up
for launch right because they know that
it's gonna it's gonna be
hot and heavy
that day
but at some point it will die down and
then spinning up all those extra servers
probably isn't worth it now again this
is just all hypothesis
um
but i think that's kind of like
why day one launch and stuff like that
always has issues is because there is a
huge influx of players right that day
one and then slowly but surely it starts
to kind of like dwindle though
and then i should probably pick that up
um
and then eventually it's like okay we've
stabilized and like now you have your
you know whoever's still playing
and you know they're fine with that um
how to change servers on ps5 i don't
know if you can i was just saying that
that is a good shout like if you can't
log in
you can definitely try a different
region on pc
i don't think that works on
so
that is a downside there if you're
having any issues
wow you just melted
[Applause]
oh we got another angelic saver i think
good day
vpn to australia works man conrad is in
it to win it today that is uh
i admire the uh
i why am i doing that deckard this is
your job
so far cow level has given the best
jewelry um for sure
oh man these shared stashes is like
diablo 3 multiple stashes can i buy more
stash tabs because i'm going to need
them
all right so we did both those
we did river flame
didn't do
oh wait i need my merc though
also i don't know if it's on purpose
maybe it is from an accessibility
standpoint
but i think new skill
sound makes the ring drop sound and then
now i just heard root like the ruined
one like you know like clicking from
waypoint to waypoint that's that's 100
the ruin dropping sound so that trips me
out a little bit because i'm so
conditioned to like hear it and then and
then you know
look start looking for the the said kind
of
um ruin that
would drop
xp is kind of going slow though not
gonna lie here
it would go faster with like a full
lobby probably but you know
we can't really
do that right now
i'm realizing my help's not even very
good
are you on switch i'm not up
um so like truth be told um from a like
review standpoint for those asking and
even noticing that ign didn't put
anything up it's probably because the
review came in sorry the the code for it
um came in like just like what
a day or two ago
which is probably really hard to get
through a game like this and write a
proper review in that sort of time
because you probably want to try you
probably also want to test server load
right maybe um for day one um and then
also you probably want to be able to
play
um
you know
online
and then check all that stuff out so i'm
guessing it's just to do that kind of
same with our reviewer
i shouldn't speak to them because i
don't know what their exact situation
but that's kind of some of the stuff
that we're going through right now
thanks
what the f server can't join i think you
got to just keep trying
sadly
every time he
dies i cannot save him fast enough
and the cryptify
i feel like the crepify is like way more
annoying than it was before
uh
bale you are my
anti i need pots potions mana potions
salutations
i've not left the game i'm still in here
afternoon
oh channel okay
yeah the offline characters won't
transfer to online so um
i was eaten by ghouls mentioned so if
you're trying to keep an online
character
um
you're gonna just have to keep trying
how does that read you not give my merch
like half his life
bale is so annoying
this decrepit by
blister is no joke man
uh
probably have to
this is what
feels bad to feel weak hello
it's probably just going to die again
yes
but every every bit of damage he does is
like so much more
when it actually like lands that it's
worth
getting him back just to speed it up for
everyone involved
sometimes you just have to wonder if
it's even hitting him properly
come on
oh that's a saigon snow i think
ah except can't really use it
i think a tower shield is saigon shield
yep plus one dollar skills
uh
i guess if we got a
if we got a plus two to clause
we'd be fine
oh is that really true kristen that it's
it's the uh whoa this is different
artwork i guess uh or not that i
remember it um saying that it doesn't
support old graphics cards or old
processors
that kind of is not so great if that's
true sorry that that's a issue
uh did we go kill everything we
basically did right oh man here we go
wish us luck chat
we did our farm runs now we're gonna try
again
how many tries will it take
only act four
no i uh oh pre-expansion yes
i am not playing offline i was playing
online
uh as you can see though making a game
ain't easy
this happened earlier we got we got
lucky and it only took like two or three
tries i think
to play online
but yeah once you leave a game
i don't know it's a crap shoot probably
um gerald when i played multiplayer
online beta it wasn't just personal loot
um it was definitely like who can pick
it up the faster er which is like not so
great you're basically my pro tip for
that
um and it might be harder on console
is when you're killing a boss
right
um
i would be holding alt and spam clicking
his body
and making sure you have inventory space
um and you just have to pray that you
click the right thing
like out of the drops and click it the
fastest that's honestly the only way
you're doing it without like hacks um in
the past there was there were hacks like
picket um where it would just
automatically pick up a certain you know
rarity type or just like all of the same
rare all of like the legendaries and set
items it would just automatically do it
um dude how can you be in hell already
well
no but uh we had early review code so
our early review code kind of like
transferred over so that's how i'm level
36 um it's not because i
just started this character obviously
would take a long time um even for me
who
i feel like i went slow it was about
almost like an hour and a half depending
server is down server is down i think
it's
still potentially up i don't know we'll
see
oh you have every right to complain
dwayne if it's broken
i think that it's a it's it can't be
frustrating like for all i know i might
not even be able to get back in right
we'll see
i mean we've been fortunate enough to be
playing for about
an
hour and maybe 20 minutes now
um
and this this was happening earlier so
maybe i'll just try this
um
i'm not gonna exit the game
in case because i don't want to fully
lose my connection to the server
an hour act is slow i don't know like i
don't it might have been more than an
hour it kind of depends right poison
donut i think it depends on if you're
doing everything in that act are you
doing all the side kind of quests too or
are you doing just the primary storyline
stuff to progress act to act if you are
um and depending on what which character
you're playing and maybe your um luck
with loot it can be faster or
slower
i didn't really time myself but it felt
like it was about an hour plus an act it
just depends
i'm just glad it doesn't seem to be
another warcraft reforged yeah that
didn't go over so hot right um
i mean we can i don't even want to go in
the lobby
i wonder if there's a difference between
nightmare games and
and and normal games right now if like
it's treated differently on the back end
i don't think so though
is this a pc only release today no i
believe people said they were on switch
and stuff like that it was just that
they um
either had problems getting on or like
got booted um
you will be as lost as us yeah i mean i
can't
do anything now about it um if i really
can't get back in right i didn't want to
leave that game
but there wasn't too much stuff left for
us to do in that that game um i guess i
could have just played through some of
the other stuff it was probably the
smarter bet
so
if anything this is probably helping
anyone that's just starting from the
beginning because you would never leave
the game unless you're trying to farm
like countess or
um here let's try nightmare just to see
if it makes a difference um
yeah
the other thing we could try to do is
like if this really doesn't work is i
can try moving some
save files into like the offline but
those save files are basically like
hacked
save files that are like kind of i don't
know
it's not as fun i feel like when you
don't
when it's not your character personally
what if you try the offline option for
us to see how smooth it goes i mean i
can it's just the that character won't
carry over but we could totally do that
yeah so as adblock everyone says the the
difference there is that like i could
totally make an offline character or
play one of these 99s but like
none of that progress or anything
carries over but we might have to do
that if we can't get back in
disconnect your internet why then the
stream goes down right
another error 37 situation i don't know
it wasn't that bad just now i love
glasses girl and i feel like i said like
like i was mentioning just now if you
were starting from scratch launch right
and you didn't get booted from your game
you're probably still playing through
your game um because
normally like you don't
um go back in act one to farm anything
really unless you're really trying to
like min max exp through like trish
trust runs or
you know um
those kind of things
but
you just be going through the like
playing through normal right and i don't
unless you got kicked you probably would
have been fine here we can um
here you want to see
uh offline here's offline
so this is offline
this is like a strafe is on that has
like just like and then
just
this one's not as bad hacked i think but
like it's it's still pretty
like uh like a six socket win for us
yeah i don't know i don't know about
that like
um like the the gear isn't
crazy crazy but you know there's
hellfire torch and string of ears
i don't know we can we can just go play
this for a little bit just so that you
know
um people aren't waiting can see
something different
you're gonna see a lot of uh
the
the hellfire torch ability though
because of straight
so if that gets um annoying
uh because it's just gonna be littered
on the screen to help me and i can
probably unequip the hellfire's torch
although on this character i don't know
how much damage that
uh mobility is doing and if we would be
struggling without it
so this is hell mode amazon accor
offline save
not not mine by any means just something
found on the internet uh not too hard to
actually put the saves in you just kind
of go to
see user
name for your your whatever user you
have on your pc
and then go to save games and then go to
the d2
folder and then if you have saves you're
just putting them into the
folder and then um
once you log into the game you'll you'll
see those
saves like the long list that you saw on
my screen
do not leave the game i shouldn't have
left the other game to be honest
but we're now playing offline just so
that people can
see the game
would like to rather progress on
online though because you know oh this
guy is
so i mean eventually like when you're
like just like oh a shaco but nothing
bright kind of should do um
you know somebody asked what the end
game is
it's kind of a lot of this right like
you just get
really good gear and you're just
continuing to try to farm more gear i
think the the other end game if you were
ever to play ladder is you just you're
trying to like if you're racing is like
you just try to get to the 99 the
fastest
and then you either do that on softcore
or hardcore ladder
yeah there ain't no end game other than
farming here yep that is correct
there's no like riffs
or greater rifts
like you're just farming
but i mean i will say some of the stuff
that you would like if you were to
legitimately like make an enigma et
cetera it would probably take a while to
get unless
they've somehow changed or tweaked any
of the drop rates
um
which if they're gonna not have hackers
they might need to do because i feel
like that stuff might be really hard to
get otherwise
um
like to get all of those ruins like i
feel like you'd have to be pretty dang
lucky um
this is pc
currently playing offline on pc
um for the time being just because we
couldn't get into an online game after i
left it like a dummy
but just showing people
some different stuff you could probably
go kill more cows if people want to see
some lulu
so i would say if anyone in chat right
now is trying to get in the game i know
it's probably frustrating and not
working if you get into a game
do your best to not leave it and just
like be patient when you're in the game
um
that's my best advice
because we are playing vine right with
some maybe minor hiccups of like
um
minor hiccups of just like some
weirdness of i couldn't id some stuff
and whatnot but for the most part the
game was still working
but some people also said and i haven't
checked this some people said that the
this like the d2r servers are down
i would have to go and confirm that
myself though
i mean normally if this character wasn't
so p you'd want to have your valkyrie
you want to make your
decoy
and again because this account is
basically like a god-tier account type
thing or well i wouldn't say god's here
but it's very strong that's why
everything is just melting and dying
hell mode is actually a lot harder than
this
um so don't take this as like oh why
does it look so easy
is that faster this guided arrow faster
and
the guided arrows faster
so that's the beauty of a uh
amazon you can
shift click attack to shoot kind of from
off screen
oh i don't have any town portal so let's
go try
let's go back and try um
let us in
uh henny batt love diablo 2 and this is
just amazing yeah very
yeah i guess that's true a six socket
when forces got here because it didn't
exist
that's totally fair i just meant like
some of the other the other items didn't
feel like it was like oh this is crazy
um crazy good at least
offline does not carry over to online
allen
oh both allen's are here
ah let us in
it's not looking good chat
it's not
looking good
i need to ban someone in chat
does that work
is that only the one message though okay
uh it's not just the fire animations
lure cipher like a lot of the different
magic animations look really good
um especially if you like you must have
played the original so you kind of have
a i mean i could well if i if i was in a
game i toggle it to show you just how
different it is but like good luck
getting in yeah i think that ship has
sailed maybe
i mean we got into what like three games
which is pretty fortuitous if you think
about it
i don't know if they remastered the
sound and some music the
it's gameplay for sure and then the
cinematics
anyone know how multiplayer works um to
some degree fallen angel just depends on
like do you have a more specific
question regarding that
okay so the other thing we could try
which is kind of like i don't know if i
want to do it is we could back out of
the game actually here's a quote uh
bt it's because i had review code had it
early that transferred over to online uh
san antonio that's how
that for to answer everyone's question
of how level 36 we had early access and
that was as much as i could kind of play
and get through in the last
12 to 24 hours um
you know because real real life stuff
and whatnot fortunate and
just
fortunate to even be able to play it
early um
but yeah
i got boosted
dude i would if i casper man if i could
right now like go make tryst runs for
like seven other people
like
i would do it yeah i'm using a leaf um
bt uh because i'm a uh
fire trap assassin right now that's
gonna eventually switch to lightning if
i i can get back in
don't exit game where you can't get back
in yeah see i didn't that thank you
thank you henny i kind of figured that
it would be even worse leaving so right
now i feel like what has to happen for
me to get into a game is somebody else
that's in if they're in has to leave and
then i have to time it at the same time
yeah i have uh i have a reviewers code
access even though i am not the reviewer
bt just a video producer
that likes the game
let us in
uh so the only other thing i can do like
i said i could go back and i have like
some other crazy like strong saves i can
do offline
were you playing with a group or solo i
was soloing
is necro now playable like do you mean
from like uh like yours your pc and the
internet being able to handle it i would
imagine so
um
i think the only thing about pl like
they're all like viable end game there's
just there's still a tier list though
right if you really wanted to get into
um
that but
uh i know that my back in the day i
hated playing with necros because like
that
that character would just lag the crap
out of my game because of all the extra
characters if they were a summoner
um
here we'll go back in and um
i don't know oh these characters don't
have any gear though they just have like
a bunch of like
stuff on them and then i don't know what
that one is must've been like a
low-level pvp
character
uh paladin stuff looks good i'm really
bad at playing hammers uh maybe because
i just never played hammers
because even though like that's like one
of the best classes like like look at
this this is this is hack city right
heart of oak
you know you got enigma
you got a spirit like jeez right like
like
okay heart evoke i could see someone
making legitimately because i don't
think those ruins are necessarily like
hard hard right but could you could you
imagine getting a jaw and a burr
um
a john a burr
in like ladder
without trading
you need to do a
uh comparison oh we have one from the um
eaten by ghouls we have done a legacy
comparison of game play um from like the
the beta and like nothing's really
changed since then to be honest other
than like being able to use different
characters
um
dude his holy shield looks so good
though um
let me
say f4
like look at how it's got like a glow to
it to the outside too
awesome oh four thousand do you remember
wasting your middle and high school
years oh i wasted so much time playing
i
like i'll admit it now because like i
had an internship one summer and i was
playing diablo
uh two with my buddy till like 3 4 5 a.m
and i i rolled out of bed to work to the
point where honestly i
i fell asleep like i fell asleep at my
desk and i got caught
by my manager and luckily
my manager was like pretty nice about it
because it was like the first time and
only time and and i wasn't very at that
time like a high performer so like i was
i was doing my job right but like i that
was that was probably like a how come
everything's dying now like i literally
tried to do an act five run and like i
was struggling the other day so like if
y'all didn't know about
um enigma how powerful that ruined word
is like this is what you can do as a
paladin right like you can teleport when
normally um you can't as a paladin right
like that is a sorceress skill i think
that's why i like diablo 2 so much it
gives you the ability
to um get abilities from the other
classes and in a meaningful way
um i don't even have a mercenary right
now but he he could have like insight
for you know the
the one pole arm that gives um
oh geez what's what's the what's the
ability hold on let me clear this out
dude hammerton is op though huh
uh what's the skill called it's um
conviction like there's the there's like
the one pole arm that gives you
conviction
get me out of there i'm damaged right
now everything's like
double
get away from me
whoa he melted
i was gonna zoom in for y'all but uh he
died
hammered in opie only op with the name i
agree that's true like that's why i
never i like when i played pally i like
never win hammers because i i just never
i was never rich enough
you know to make it work
i mean
i wouldn't i wouldn't say
i would still say hammers is still
strong though osmo i think that it's
like not as efficient and fast though
without enigma right so like farming
speed and all that's probably
a lot worse without enigma but
um the the actual ability itself
i think is probably still very strong
and viable um
like ladder right like i think it's
still a very like an s-tier type ladder
class um
because you can just get plus skills and
stuff like that right either like
like easy cheap ways of getting plus
skills like ambulance helmets um
you know all that fun stuff
but yeah like once you have enigma it's
kind of like pretty
you broken probably you know what one
sec
i'm definitely i you know what i wish i
was getting paid by um
if you that's what you think uh what is
his name
goluga garc
i think that's his name i wish
not only would i be
somehow doubling my uh
income i guess but you know my wife my
wife would be happy like oh sweet i need
money
like i've
forever like i i've genuinely always
loved diablo like it's like one of my
gay like it's it's interesting that like
my the games that i played the most
they all start with the letter d
so diablo
dark souls although like it was
bloodborne first
um
destiny
like those are the games i've actually
put the most like hours into um
and in two of those cases they're like
looters
and i guess that makes sense because i
just like
farming
and destroying monsters to then
therefore get loot
um
i don't know
let's go check out another area
[Music]
to arms buff on cali i don't need well
maybe you know what
nope i was gonna say maybe i do have it
but no i have a uh i have a tall war of
alibaba that probably just has like it's
probably for mf
i don't know not my character so we can
go check the stash i don't even know
what's in the stash
hi you guys y'all need some runes uh
i've got plenty of ruins for y'all if i
could give them to you
how did anyone know how he has enigma
already uh this is offline
because online is not working right now
um
andrew i think that even getting a
enigma online
on
on uh
online right now one would probably be
dang near possible because like you said
like i don't think most people have it
right have or far enough and two i think
legitimately
getting it might be pretty hard
right
now
oh
you want to see what that is i get an
idea
i don't die this on this
i can't carry anything
it's the reaver
also apologies in advance so if my
hammer play is poor
i've never
gotten to play hammers with enigma so
pretty much just feeling it through you
know
[Applause]
[Applause]
play the xbox version
risky risky
see like what i don't understand is like
how it like the hammer shred sometimes
like in act 4 it was just shredding
right then here it's like
i feel like it's not as efficient also
this poison is so real
i don't think the guy the the person's
account
uh
has
but maybe he just didn't need it back
then i don't know
and i'm about to die so
how may i be of help
give me potions
yeah i like don't know why it felt like
so much stronger in act 4 just now than
act 5.
currently playing as assassin nice tanya
enjoy way to get in
i'm actually kind of scared to go into
chaos angry
just feel like i'm gonna botch it
somehow you know
now
like look at all the abilities from the
oblivion it looks so good
that's also why i'm scared because
there's probably just going to be so
much stuff on the screen in a second
here
who knows that panic
pot uh potion spamming because you
definitely heard me do it there just now
trying my best one to not die and two to
not make a fool of myself but
surely i will probably die here
i feel like
mana pods
i need
oh
not enough mana
sorry if i'm not reading uh
chat right now um this is
for whatever reason a lot harder than
playing that uh boson that we were
playing earlier that like i feel like i
could just face roll because
she was based she basically had enough
like um life steal that she could just
kind of sit there and face tank
oh no we're out of mana potions
there it is
there is the death i teleported right
into them that was good
and we don't even have a way back
so
we just joined a new game i guess
imagine having enigma day one yeah
there's no way there's no way right like
i i don't even see how people could get
it online
um legitimately at least like this is
this is a save account right
um
man
well f in chat put the f's in chat i
yeah
rip rip
redeem
same questions over yeah that's what
happens john
figure your way back ah yeah i probably
should have no that's a good point
robert um
i don't know i guess i just like i don't
really enjoy hammerton
maybe maybe that's just me
like i'd rather play that face roll
strafe
uh amazon because it's just like
i don't have to think i press a button
things die
i don't die this is the dream you know
not enough mana
dude the teleport animation i don't know
everyone saw it but like it leaves a
little bit of like a lightning crackle
at the end which is like really cool
all right we're gonna give chaos
sanctuary one more run here
hopefully i
can do it
i need mana i'm just gonna avoid those
guys
know
nope
dude that i oh you know what it is i
think this character has like minus 60
fire resistance that's probably how i
died to the the freaking
venom awards just because they they spit
hot fire
sick
apparently chad's not happy about the
same questions being asked
ah it's okay i don't blame y'all
uh
god
oh
and for those asking if chad hasn't
already told you we're offline right now
that's why i have such a high level
character
it's not my save
i need money
jeez
this is hard work
do you remember that that strafe is on
we were playing shoes well i guess we
did have like a super hacked wind wars
but still
okay
that would probably help having holy
shield up geez
dude won't diablo like shred me because
he's fire
what was i thinking
oh cool and they have conviction that's
that's really fair
like
they just all of a sudden disappear
all right
see how this goes
like do half the hammers not hit
see
and then he melts right
he melts
is this guy a speedrunner no way
rb conviction yeah
and these if you didn't know these
essences they help you if you get all
five of them from the hell bosses the
main bosses you get a uh
re-roll basically
what do you need but that was a
run of uh
all right we're gonna try to get back in
to the servers has anyone tried i'm
guessing everyone's trying right
and using redeem
that broad
oh
you are standing in the wrong spot okay
gotcha
thanks kenshin this is coming from a
real good
perspective of not really playing
hammers so
my bad
my left shoulder and that hammer delay
hit yeah
[Music]
i will remember that though kenshin
i was the one that gave you the scar in
your face too just i know
it says they are still investigating so
we have to play
um
[Music]
offline basically right
uh
let me check something
yeah i think we got to play offline i
don't think we have a choice huh
well we had it good in the beginning
right
i must say
how can he already have all the items
we're hammered in it's an offline here
i'm gonna show you because we can't get
online this is offline i pulled in saves
of like
different characters just from online
you can pull old save files into your
offline it doesn't matter
um
yes there's the servers do not work
right now i will uh
i think this trap assassin
has like a bunch of stuff too
um
yeah
uh
[Music]
so this is what it would look like if we
were playing a lightning assassin
which we also have gameplay
this one is like extremely broken like
the the items on it are like disgusting
versus speech
and then look what happens when we turn
off burst of speed just like oh here we
go we're sonic the hedgehog
oh it's probably down there i think
oh so there's uh this is uh there's wake
of inferno but the fires i've never
actually seen them that looks pretty
crazy
i'm dylan i spent fire
um and then we could do corpse explode
too
oh well i don't know why the corpse
explode looks exactly the same as um
you can barely see the corpse explosion
just so everyone knows this is offline
i'm gonna say i probably have to say it
multipliers
it's an offline
like hacked character basically
why one i'm not dying because
everything's just melting
we can only make a character and only
talk
i enjoy talking to everyone here
thanks for hanging out
we stream um
semi-regularly we don't have consistent
days but anytime there's an event
or like a big game release or something
like that we tend to stream so
if you haven't subscribed or given us
that like
it doesn't just hurt
and really appreciate everyone hanging
out
and all the sage advice and wisdom that
people
have given me
change the title to offline
uh i mean there's no point in this
like
no point i also feel like we technically
for the first
hour and 20 minutes did get to play
online
so you know i
take comfort in that
[Applause]
that could be a good sign
what's everyone's favorite like
legendary item go
[Music]
[Applause]
i think mine might be like
oh man
it's really hard to say because i guess
you could go class by class
like shaco has always been nice vamp
gays is really nice um
[Applause]
t-gods for java
like
oh you know what we could do i think
that amazon has lightning theory we can
check that out too
oh goal yeah
[Applause]
shaco materials might oh a couple tears
my storm shield yeah storm shield's
legit azure
rat wizards oh whiz spike that's right
oh man whis spike was so good
oh crap wait is he leaving
we're just melting through because this
character's just broken
oh i'm actually running out of mana
that's not good
i'm playing offline right now people are
asking how am i playing wow we get the
blood splatter noise after the fact
that's cool
i like lightning jab was on but you
almost never see that yeah i mean it
kind of it's actually i think it's not a
bad cloud here we got we got um some
nice
we got a ethereal
why why
can't i why can't i put this in the
stash
all right whatever it doesn't matter
uh
titans revenge
nice little f1 let's see
oh cool this skill is level 99 no wonder
it's just gonna absolutely shred
um no problem right uh okay
where haven't we gone
uh what has a lot of oh you know what do
i have a words like we could just
destroy a bunch of cows right uh
maybe i don't use this yet
uh let me let me save the
uh oh there it is
let me get word's leg and then we'll do
cow level
lightning jabba the cows
how's that sound
off just so you know offline
uh
i would imagine all these characters are
hacked or like had the character editor
back in the day
you can move over your um offline saves
they just don't transfer over to online
so they don't really care if you kind of
like
enjoy your yourself here on the offline
stuff
okay let me go buy a tome on this
character i keep forgetting that she
doesn't have a tone
i don't know why you wouldn't have a
tone
maybe just for inventory space reasons
oh raven frost is another good um
they're actually bulls not cows okay
fair enough but they still call it the
cow level right in uh in this so if
anything i'll go tell i'll go tell them
that they screwed that one up
uh also confirmed earlier if you weren't
here in chat that um
you can kill the cow king and uh still
[Music]
continue to make
cow level so
that's
awesome news i need another oh no does
this character not have a freaking
herod's cube yes
that okay well we're just gonna go
lightning chat with somewhere else then
because
let me go check the stash i don't think
i saw it in the stash but maybe i just
wasn't paying attention oh no okay it
does have a cube thank goodness
i can't
what do you mean you can't
oh
why are you what is this
that's how we're alibaba okay make sense
we're gonna get another town portal
just so that i don't forget
put the cube away and then we will go do
some
lightning cows lightning cows
okay
all right here we go lightning fury
you know what's funny is uh i think poe
2 basically has like lightning jabba or
like lightning like basically the
ability first very similar
man lightning jabs on very
good and i gotta make sure i don't like
throw them all
throw it 133 more times can chat
remember can they can they count me down
[Music]
i think i have like uh
115 left 30 minute maintenance all right
here we go
how is the audio with gamespot worse
than small-time youtubers uh which which
side of it like my gameplay audio or the
uh my microphone audio
because my microphone audio yeah i agree
um i don't i don't have like a
i just have a headset mic because i
normally don't make uh too much voice
over content for the site anymore so
you rarely see me well you actually
don't even see me right now
there's the cow king
who is immune to lightning which is
awesome great
i can't carry anymore
yeah i could uh i could do it with throw
right so
oh and whatever it's fine
so we'll know that we have 119
good shout outs
yeah that's true too kenshin that uh it
should pop up the red
kind of uh indicator when i'm low on
javelins that's a good that's also a
good shot do we already
kind of clear it
i feel like we did huh
i mean
yeah when you have a level 99
lightning javelin
i guess
things just die i do i do also greek
engine that i like the uh addition of
the uh armor and the helmet on the cow
king that way you kind of know
who uh
who he is i guess although in this case
they didn't lock you out of it which is
cool
i need to get rid of this person
in chat
i know we haven't done too much act
three right we'll just
randomly go somewhere
[Music]
please do hardcore mode i mean i i could
make a hardcore offline character it'd
be very like unentertaining though for
the time being
no run speed yeah not in this character
um
yeah i don't
i'm debating if like
i'll still be around for like post
maintenance
i think that will probably rap before
then to be honest although i guess at
the same time i'm your only form of
entertainment until you get the uh
until you get it working so i'll at
least be around until maintenance goes
down and then we'll we'll go check it
out a little bit but um for the time
being
we'll press on with the
lightning jab here
stuff just dies huh
oh you know what we should try
what does this look like
okay so it's more pronounced i guess
than than it used to be
because like you can definitely poison
javelin your way through a good amount
of like when you when you're starting um
is there anything else that's kind of
cool
like what poison javelin looks like
yeah okay
you only see the animation when you
actually hit someone all right
yeah uh you just hit well
i don't know i can't remember off the
top of my head what the button is for um
console but on pc you just hit the
letter g and you can easily go back and
forth
you can play like this for a little bit
too if you want to see like what
lightning jab looked like before
i mean not shabby right but
oh does it not do the arc that it does
when you're
now that's the same
we have time traveled
uh
i think i prefer this version
i mean it it like it was working earlier
we'll see how bad it gets over the next
couple days like
i don't know how many people played
outriders when it first came out but
that was kind of tough too
but their smaller company right
oh you know what else we should try
all right let's see
exploding arrow
and
hold arrow
wait is there another
i could do ice arrow
i just wanted to check out the animation
stop
dodging
it's like he knows
what is this
come back sir
oh wow
okay
pretty good
pretty good man i wanna i i need a
sorceress
i need a sorceress
uh
she probably gets like the most out of
this
like in terms of just like visual
effects
like even the hydras looked really good
[Applause]
13 minutes ago
yes this is offline
no choice
nothing's working but i am glad that i
put some um
some
quote-unquote hacked saves so that we
could still play and just check out
stuff
anyway and i said like i said earlier it
was working um when we first started the
stream which is more surprising to me
unless it's because people like maybe
over time as the launch window has
opened more people have tried to get on
and maybe that's kind of like what's
causing some of the um
extra
burden because when we first started we
didn't i didn't have too many issues
getting in and on but it definitely
escalated right
look at those
hydras man
the hydras are like
wrecking my uh
all that wrecking but
she's not happy about it
it was killed on this difficulty really
oh thanks for that insight fell to
belthorus sorry if i butchered your name
i like that's that's really cool like
that's just like
some nice
insight um i guess i just never really
i don't know i just never really
i guess i did maybe i just never came to
travel cold that much like
back in the day i think it was a lot of
like bail or like meth for me like cow i
guess
you saw pandemonium forest
um
go here maybe
10 minutes for the rest of our lives
that's true
they're actually kind of crazy how like
a level 99 lightning theory doesn't just
maybe like one or two shot them
they're trying to one-shot it on
hardcore godspeed godspeed
wait how am i playing i'm playing
offline
maybe that person was right earlier that
i uh that i forget the name of but maybe
uh there does need to be like a title
change although in theory
if mates goes right in 10 minutes it
won't matter
as it knew as a noob that only ever
played multi-shot as an amazon or
lightning
was exploding
arrow or like was that viable
i guess you would need another skill
though because if they're firing me you
probably got some problems
yeah some i think maintenance is about
10 more minutes is what folks are saying
maybe if i play in this mode everyone
will be like yeah
the servers are offline he's playing on
he's playing on that classic you know
but surprise
oh we're gonna run out of arrows that's
awkward oh
what perfect timing
oh we had more anyways
wait
these are what
excuse me are
those are fake right
warp needle all right
is this something i just don't know
about
what program did you use that i didn't
use anything to edit i downloaded safes
to be honest with you i
the the most hacking i ever did in
diablo was i had the map pack and i had
pick it that's that's really all i ever
had
in my lifetime playing diablo 2 i've
only ever found one sage
ever legitimately dropped
that wasn't like from a trade or a duke
so
oh you know what else is really good um
legendary or unique um
what's the wiz what's the wizard uh
oculus i guess like plus three to skills
because that thing was like really good
too
it's like you go shaco
that thing like skin of the viper
magi or whatever like that's so many
plus skill already
playing offline off a someone else's
save
should only be you know hopefully
eminent for most folks though
and then we can test the theory too
i have something
yeah i don't remember what it is it's
like the
i just know it gave plus three to skills
right
i think funny enough i don't even think
this has multi shot
ah
that's not how it looked like before
right magic arrow
i guess it's okay
oh
[Music]
these are like skills that i would never
actually use so like i or i haven't used
in the past and i just don't remember
what it looks like so it's kind of like
visually looks a lot better right
yeah servers are in maintenance right
now so no choice but to play offline
and just showing off some different
areas that maybe people haven't seen a
remaster
hanging out
chilling
again really appreciate everyone hanging
out chatting asking questions
reliving the nostalgia
oculus oh which is just oculus
that's probably it
i just thought it was like something
more in depth i guess but i guess not
geez this emulation arrow is kind of
crazy looking
it's like a it just drops like a flame
carpet basically
it's locked
sure is
they look pretty cool right like
fully like they got full armor
they like they actually attack like
heartbeats kind of in a way where like
they like attack with their feet
live this eye okay there we go
the oculus was like the weapon type
right
i like barely ever went into these
things
i i think i like always try to just get
through act five because like it felt
long
and you had to like really
like
run through a lot of places to get to
where you needed
yeah this is offline
could you imagine having uh this kind of
character already day one
and lightning
lightning jab was just not cutting it
huh
these guys kind of look cool
pretty good detail on the face too
people want to see your face
oh wow they have masks on huh pretty
cool
all right sorry about that sorry about
these
zoom-ins admiring some of the
remastering
uh cooper last it was like 30 minutes
like from a little bit ago so
i think some people have said like four
or five minutes in chat as they've been
kind of keeping track so hopefully
next four minutes unless they decide to
tweet they need more time which
not gonna lie does happen from time to
time so
stay tuned probably
oh
the old day one woes right
all right someone's keeping track right
i'm back in
all right i trust wink zero because
zero's been here from the beginning
no
you said you were back in wing zero
i trusted you you were the chosen one
all right we're back online
come on we got you got to be quick you
got to be quick because if if it just
came back you got to get in before
everyone else gets in
otherwise you're gonna be stuck in like
a fake q so to speak i'm actually
surprised they haven't done like a q yet
i'm not back in wing zero
but i mean uh
week zero legitimately has been here
from the beginning so i i wouldn't be
shocked if they actually did get back in
this was my worst nightmare yeah i i
feel like
weirdly to say and it sucks though is
that
you don't wanna like plan too much for
day one because it's just gonna be a
crap shoot
um
character already on server
i live in central america probably
nobody getting online near me oh man
i'll probably give this a couple tries
and then if it doesn't work we'll
probably just
um
call it a stream because i feel like we
did a lot
um
the other thing i could try doing but i
don't i feel like since we got to the
main menu is like like
possibly closing the the client and
reopening it but like
i don't know
i'm a cheater with the hacks yeah i
guess so with the offline characters
i don't think the game is a crap shoot i
think that any any big
game that has a
online component to it with servers is a
crap shoot and like historically you can
just look at
most games and their launch days and and
i think that's probably going to be true
a lot of the time sadly when it's an all
online game
there's gonna be some
portion of the population that's
probably able to get in and at some
point they'll probably enable like a
queueing
type system where like at least
it feels like it's less frustrating
because you see a number counting down
instead of like this right where you're
constantly spamming i guess i didn't
read the message that it messaged but
like
you know
i
like hey i i was willing not personally
almost by resurrected on two platforms
because there isn't cross play
um oh my game is on the game server you
know what all right i'm doing i'm doing
something i probably shouldn't do
but we're gonna try it um
hold on
we're gonna try it
and just see for science for other folks
if this helps or makes things worse it
might make things worse
oops
this character is already in a game
server please try again
oh i got in
we are in you just gotta have
perseverance
uh
but now that i say that i'm in like i
was actually ready to end the stream so
let's just uh i guess we'll do one cow
run for fun
and we'll probably call it a day
but uh let's let's go do another cow run
since we're in
this is online this is not a offline um
basically cobbled hacked together
character this is my character
using a leaf and a stealth
the only other things i have that are
cool that i've gotten is a nagel and a
saigon's wrap everything else is kind of
pretty mediocre either set items or
legendary uniques that i've got
i could find um the old portal here that
would be
oh there you go speak of the devil
and he shall appear
launch day online is a blow up let's
hold it hopes let's hope that it holds
out yeah i hope soon
one last cow run for the road and then
i'll take
if there's something else that like you
really want to see then we can
potentially take a look at it but
probably going to call it after that
just because it's a bunch of other stuff
got to get through and
i might even have to help finish that
diablo 2 tips video they're very kind of
just like for the for the new player
though um
just stuff veterans probably already
know but
uh good afternoon you know there's
different tips about like the roger cube
and
um
which starter class might be right for
you and there and
i don't know
that one's a tricky one though because
like i feel like if you say sorceress is
like really hard because she is frail in
the beginning like some people are gonna
be like up in arms because sorceress is
probably arguably like one of the best
characters
to play as your first character on
ladder because
blizzard's really strong
has teleport which is just a really good
skill
has ways to really just get extra damage
for free and away from like getting a
bunch of plush skills
let's try to get like a big old herd of
cows huh or bulls as as someone
corrected me earlier because they're not
oh no
at the cost of my mercenary
[Music]
oh you know what we can test because i'm
not afraid because i'm not worried about
getting logged off is we can test the
lobby later and see if we can like
actually make games
not right
probably helped that burst of speed on
[Music]
[Music]
right north
[Music]
oh he's right over he's over here i
think there he is
there's cow king
he's getting stuck by his buddies though
as you can see he has a nice little
crown
[Music]
i'm gonna die
[Music]
so yeah servers are back up on pc uh you
might not get in like just right away
like you might have to spam a little bit
i exited the game and came back that
helped me but it still took me like an
extra try
so
mileage may vary right now
i think that's most of the cows
maybe a pack or two left here
it's a small pack
is there anything anyone else wants to
see
other than maybe checking the lobbies in
a second before i uh
quote-unquote turn off the stream
your request no
keep forgetting burst of speed not
enough mana
hello
how are you so far it's uh because i had
um early access
5mf review code
wow three ms blizzard and two meteor we
got to sell that in another
uh
town
obvious reasons
amazon's face i'd have to go back to the
character screen to do that
but i see where i i see the angle you're
trying to approach it from
and the amazon doesn't appreciate it you
know
can you gamble items for a while i mean
i don't know if i have enough money to
gamble for a while i can go gamble a
couple things good day
yes
i think i mean nice john brown you've
been here since the beginning too i
think we're like close to the beginning
let's see how much gold do i have i
probably could buy like two amulets if
if that um
what's the best thing to gamble uh i
don't like
what would you like me to gamble on oh
wow they changed the ancient armor look
oh no it's just because that one's just
a different color
like rings and
i can buy four rings
or i can buy
three well i can't even buy four rings
because she only has so many things to
buy here
ah those boots were bad
uh
not so good level six ring feels good oh
wait okay they replenish my bad
wow
her ring the rings are bad
the rings are bad man
all right i can afford one more before i
i can't swallow it okay all right that
was a terrible experiment
it was fun while it lasted
um
i feel like i have a better home than
what i'm wearing right
i don't
this helm is so bad
these boots are so bad
didn't we trade didn't we swap the boots
earlier i think it rolled back
a little bit maybe
oh it totally rolled back the servers
rolled back
i don't have that 15 mf ring that i
found earlier on stream and those rare
boots that weren't even that good that i
put on i don't have those anymore either
i do luckily have the 30 mf
uh neck that we got earlier but it
definitely
oh wow and all the extra drops that we
got
they're all gone
from in the shared stash remember how i
put a bunch in here
so the servers rolled back
a little bit it looks like or when i was
playing it just didn't stick whatever a
little amount of
time there was there
so hey mileage may vary today uh have
fun happy diablo 2
resurrected day
appreciate everyone stopping by i'm
hanging out chatting
if you want to
uh we have a cinematics comparison the
old new all of them
uh we have some gameplay
up you probably just saw some of it that
i i put up that was like cow level and
stuff like that and we should hopefully
have some tips coming and then hopefully
the review
um not sure timing on that you know
maybe if we're lucky
maybe tomorrow i don't know if not early
next week
but that's kind of what's going on and i
hope everyone has a great time and i
hope everyone's able to log in
so until next time
thank you
[Music]
i